une petite bibliothèque dans une petite
municipalité qui porte maintenant le nom
d'une femme en avance sur son temps une
femme qui a contribué à écrire
l'histoire du Québec mais qu'on ne
connaît que très peu je pense que il y a
une page d'histoire qui est oubliée la
mairesse de l'île Verte s'est donné pour
objectif de sortir robertine Barry de
l'oubli je me disais ça se peut pas
qu'on aille un personnage aussi
important qui est né sur le territoire
de l'île verte puis qu'on souligne rien
né en 1863 robertine Barry devient la
première femme journaliste du Canada
français c'est dans ce village côtier
qu'elle voit le jour dans une famille
bourgeoise du bassin Laurent une époque
où le clergé est tout-puissant mais
robertine n'hésite pas à se battre pour
le suffrage féminin ou l'instruction
laïque
et elle 200 ans ou 150 temps avant ce
qu'on est aujourd'hui
offert vraiment ce qu'elle voulait faire
ça a pas déjà être facile non plus
Sergine Desjardins a aussi appris
l'existence de robertine Barry un peu
par hasard lorsqu'elle était dans une
librairie et qu'un livre lui
littéralement tombé sur la tête j'ai
tiré un livre sur une tablette et puis
ce qui m'est tombé sur la tête c'est une
très petite biographie de peine une
centaine de pages très très petite le
titre c'était robertine Barry
l'écrivaine est rapidement intrigué par
les idées modernes de robertine Barry
que ce soit sur l'éducation des femmes
ou la laïcité elle qui a même fondé sa
propre revue Le Journal de Françoise
plus faisait des recherches sur elle je
me rendais compte à quel point elle
était avant-gardiste puis j'étais il y
avait quelque chose un sentiment
d'injustice parce que je me dis pourquoi
on a retenu les noms des premières
féministes alors que les idées à elle
était en avance sur ces premières
féministes
pendant plus de trois ans Sergine
Desjardins épluge des centaines de pages
écrites par robertine Barry elle y
découvre une femme drôle et insoumise
qui menait une vie complètement à
contre-courant robertine se baladait à
vélo dans le vieux Montréal elle
travaillait pour honorer Beaugrand
aurait fréquenté aimé negan et choisit
de ne jamais se marier elle disait je
préfère être capable de rire parce que
je suis vieille fille que de ne plus
rien du tout parce que je suis mariée
pour rendre hommage à robertine Sergine
lui consacre une longue biographie dont
elle nous lit un extrait robertine
savait que le simple fait d'écrire
émancipation de la femme pouvait lui
aliéner bien des esprits vous avez peur
des femmes qui parlent d'autres choses
que de chiffon ou de chaudron stéphanie
pelty a aussi appris à connaître
robertine Barry elle a incarné au
théâtre dans une petite pièce présentée
à l'île verte et à Rimouski la
comédienne est aussi tombé sous le
charme de robertine elle faisait des
choses qui sont encore aujourd'hui
difficiles à entendre pour certaines
personnes alors on était en 1900 tu dis
si elle était aujourd'hui en 2023
quelque part moi je voudrais aller
prendre une bière avec et je voudrais
aller jaser avec je voudrais que ce soit
ma pote Stéphanie Pelletier qui a
elle-même fait des études féministes
s'explique mal qu'on ne connaisse pas
mieux robertine Barry c'est fort de se
dire qu'on en entend pas parler et puis
j'ai l'impression que peut-être que son
histoire était dessus parce qu'elle a
trop choquée ça va être installé dans le
courant du printemps cette plaque sera
bientôt installée dans la bibliothèque
de l'île verte et la petite municipalité
pense déjà à d'autres façons de rendre
hommage à robertine Barry il pourrait
avoir une rue il pourrait avoir
peut-être un parc on a des beaux parcs à
l'île Verte autant de façons de ne pas
oublier cette pionnière qui est morte à
Montréal seul et isolé à seulement 46
ans après une vie passée à
contre-courant sans jamais voir le fruit
de ses efforts